[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
ERIK DEMAINE: Good morning.
AUDIENCE: Morning!
ERIK DEMAINE: Welcome to 006,
Introduction to Algorithms,
lecture two.
I am Erik Demaine and
I love algorithms.
Are you with me?
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
Today, we're not
doing algorithms.
No, we're doing data structures.
It's OK.
There's lots of algorithms
in each data structure.
It's like multiple
algorithms for free.
We're going to talk
about sequences,
and sets, and linked
lists, and dynamic arrays.
Fairly simple data
structures today.
This is the beginning of
several data structures
we'll be talking about
in the next few lectures.
But before we actually
start with one,
let me tell you/remind remind
you of the difference between
an interface-- which
you might call an API
if you're a programmer, or
an ADT if you're an ancient
algorithms person like me--
versus a data structure.
These are useful distinctions.
The idea is that an interface
says what you want to do.
A data structure
says how you do it.
So you might call
this a specification.
And in the context
of data structures,
we're trying to store some data.
So the interface will specify
what data you can store,
whereas the data
structure will give you
an actual representation and
tell you how to store it.
This is pretty boring.
Just storing data
is really easy.
You just throw it in
a file or something.
What makes it interesting is
having operations on that data.
In the interface, you specify
what the operations do,
what operations are
supported, and in some sense,
what they mean.
And the data structure
actually gives you algorithms--
this is where the
algorithms come in--
for how to support
those operations.
All right.
In this class, we're going to
focus on two main interfaces
and various special of them.
The idea is to separate what you
want to do versus how to do it.
Because-- you can think of
this as the problem statement.
Yesterday-- or, last class,
Jason talked about problems
and defined what a problem was
versus algorithmic solutions
to the problem.
And this is the analogous notion
for data structures, where
we want to maintain
some data according
to various operations.
The same problem can be
solved by many different data
structures.
And we're going to see that.
And different data
structures are going
to have different advantages.
They might support some
operations faster than others.
And depending on
what you actually
use those data
structures for, you
choose the right data structure.
But you can maintain
the same interface.
We're going to think
about two data structures.
One is called a set and
one is called a sequence.
These are highly loaded terms.
Set means something
to a mathematician.
It means something else
to a Python programmer.
Sequence, similarly.
I guess there's not a Python
sequence data type built in.
The idea is, we want
to store n things.
The things will be
fairly arbitrary.
Think of them as
integers or strings.
And on the one hand, we
care about their values.
And maybe we want to
maintain them in sorted order
and be able to search
for a given value, which
we'll call a key.
And on the other hand, we
care about representing
a particular sequence
that we care about.
Maybe we want to represent
the numbers 5, 2, 9,
7 in that order and store that.
In Python, you could store
that in a list, for example.
And it will keep
track of that order.
And this is the first item,
the second item, the last item.
Today, we're going to be
focusing on this sequence data
structure, although
at the end, I'll
mention the interface for sets.
But we're going to be actually
solving sequences today.
And in the next
several lectures,
we'll be bouncing back
and forth between these.
They're closely related.
Pretty abstract at the moment.
On the other hand, we're
going to have two main--
let's call them data
structure tools or approaches.
One is arrays and the
other is pointers--
pointer-based or
linked data structures.
You may have seen these.
They're used a lot in
programming, of course.
But we're going to see
both of these today.
I'll come back to this sort
of highlight in a moment.
Let's jump into the sequence
interface, which I conveniently
have part of here.
There's a few different
levels of sequences
that we might care about.
I'm going to start with the
static sequence interface.
This is where the number
of items doesn't change,
though the actual items might.
Here, we have n items.
I'm going to label them x 0
to x n minus 1, as in Python.
So the number of items is n.
And the operations I want
to support are build,
length, iteration, get, and set.
So what do these do?
Build is how you get started.
To build a data structure
in this interface,
you call build of x.
Exactly how you specify x isn't
too important, but the idea is,
I give you some
items in some order.
In Python, this
would be an iterable.
I'm going to want to
also know its length.
And I want to make a new
data structure of size
and a new static
sequence of size n
that has those
items in that order.
So that's how you
build one of these.
Because somehow, we
have to specify n
to this data structure,
because n is not
going to be allowed to change.
I'm going to give
you a length method.
Methods are the
object-oriented way
of thinking of operations
that your interface supports.
Length will just return
this fixed value n.
Iter sequence.
This is the sense in which we
want to maintain the order.
I want to be able to output
x 0 through x n minus 1
in the sequence order,
in that specified order
that they were built in
or that it was changed to.
This is going to iterate
through all of the items.
So it's going to take at least
linear time to output that.
But more interesting is, we
can dynamically access anywhere
in the middle of the sequence.
We can get the ith item,
x i, given the value i,
and we can change x i
to a given new item.
OK.
So that's called
get_at and set_at.
Pretty straightforward.
This should remind you
very closely of something--
a data structure.
So this is an interface.
This is something I
might want to solve.
But what is the
obvious data structure
that solves this problem?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: A list.
ERIK DEMAINE: A list.
In Python, it's called a list.
I prefer to call it an
array, but to each their own.
We're going to use "list."
List could mean many
things, but the solution
to this interface problem--
the natural solution-- is
what I'll call a static array.
Jason mentioned
these in lecture one.
It's a little
tricky because there
are no static arrays in Python.
There are only
dynamic arrays, which
is something we will get to.
But I want to talk about, what
is a static array, really?
And this relates
to our notion of--
our model of computation,
Jason also talked about,
which we call the
word RAM, remember?
The idea, in word RAM,
is that your memory
is an array of w-bit words.
This is a bit circular.
I'm going to define an array
in terms of the word RAM, which
is defined in terms of arrays.
But I think you know the idea.
So we have a big memory which
goes off to infinity, maybe.
It's divided into words.
Each word here is w bits long.
This is word 0, word 1, word 2.
And you can access
this array randomly--
random access memory.
So I can give you the number
5 and get 0 1, 2, 3, 4,
5, the fifth word in this RAM.
That's how actual memories work.
You can access any of
them equally quickly.
OK, so that's memory.
And so what we want to do
is, when we say an array,
we want this to be a
consecutive chunk of memory.
Let me get color.
Let's say I have an array
of size 4 and it lives here.
Jason can't spell,
but I can't count.
So I think that's four.
We've got-- so the array starts
here and it ends over here.
It's of size 4.
And it's consecutive,
which means,
if I want to access
the array at position--
at index i, then this
is the same thing
as accessing my memory
array at position--
wherever the array
starts, which I'll
call the address of the array--
in Python, this is ID of array--
plus i.
OK.
This is just simple
offset arithmetic.
If I want to know the
0th item of the array,
it's right here,
where it starts.
The first item is
one after that.
The second item
is one after that.
So as long as I store my
array consecutively in memory,
I can access the array
in constant time.
I can do get_at and
set_at as quickly
as I can randomly access
the memory and get value--
or set a value-- which we're
assuming is constant time.
My array access
is constant time.
This is what allows
a static array
to actually solve this problem
in constant time per get_at
and set_at operation.
This may seem simple, but we're
really going to need this model
and really rely on this model
increasingly as we get to more
interesting data structures.
This is the first time
we're actually needing it.
Let's see.
Length is also constant time.
We're just going to
store that number
n, along with its address.
And build is going
to take linear time.
Iteration will take linear time.
Pretty straightforward.
I guess one thing
here, when defining
build, I need to introduce
a little bit more
of our model of
computation, which
is, how do you create an
array in the beginning?
I claim I could do
it in linear time,
but that's just
part of the model.
This is called the
memory allocation model.
There are a few
possible choices here,
but the cleanest one
is just to assume
that you can allocate an array
of size n in theta n time.
So it takes linear time to
make an array of size n.
You could imagine
this being constant.
It doesn't really matter much.
But it does take work.
And in particular, if you just
allocate some chunk of memory,
you have no idea whether
it's initialized.
So initializing that array
to 0s will cost linear time.
It won't really matter,
constant versus linear,
but a nice side effect of
this model is that space--
if you're just
allocating arrays,
the amount of space you use
is, at most, the amount of time
you use.
Or, I guess, big O of that.
So that's a nice feature.
It's pretty weird
if you imagine--
it's unrealistic to imagine you
can allocate an array that's
infinite size and then just
use a few items out of it.
That won't give you a
good data structure.
So we'll assume it costs
to allocate memory.
OK, great.
We solved the sequence problem.
Very simple, kind of boring.
These are optimal running times.
Now, let's make it interesting--
make sure I didn't miss
anything--
and talk about-- oh,
there is one thing I want
to talk about in the word RAM.
A side effect of this assumption
that array access should
take constant time, and that
accessing these positions
in my memory should
take constant time,
is that we need to assume
w is at least log n or so.
w, remember, is the
machine word size.
In real computers,
this is currently 64--
or 256, in some
bizarre instructions.
But we don't usually
think of the machine
as getting bigger over time, but
you should think of the machine
as getting bigger over time.
This is a statement
that says, the word
size has to grow with n.
It might faster
than log n, but it
has to grow at least
as fast as log n.
Why do I say that?
Because if I have n things
that I'm dealing with-- n,
here, is the problem size.
Maybe it's the array I'm
trying to store-- whatever.
If I'm having to deal with
n things in my memory,
at the very least, I need
to be able to address them.
I should be able to
say, give me the ith one
and represent that
number i in a word.
Otherwise-- because the machine
is designed to only work
with w-bit words
in constant time,
they'll want to be
able to access the ith
word in constant time,
I need a word size
that's at least log n just
to address that and n things
in my input.
So this is a totally
reasonable assumption.
It may seem weird because
you think of a real machine
as having constant
size, but a real machine
has constant size RAM, also.
My machine has 24 gigs
of RAM, or whatever.
That laptop has 8.
But you don't think of
that as changing over time.
But of course, if you want
it to process a larger input,
you would buy more RAM.
So eventually, when our
n's get really, really big,
we're going to have
to increase w just
so we can address that RAM.
That's the intuition here.
But this is a way to
bridge reality, which are
fixed machines, with theory.
In.
Algorithms, we care about
scalability for very large n.
We want to know what that
growth function is and ignore
the lead constant factor.
That's what asymptotic
notation is all about.
And for that, we need a notion
of word size also changing
in this asymptotic way.
All right.
That would be more
important next week,
when we talk about
hashing and why hashing
is a reasonable thing to do.
But let's move on to
dynamic sequences, which is
where things get interesting.
I have the update here.
We start with static sequences.
All of these
operations are still
something we want to support
in a dynamic sequence,
but we add two
dynamic operations--
somewhat controversial
operations, very exciting.
I want to be able to insert
in the middle of my sequence
and I want to be able to delete
from the middle of my sequence.
Here's my sequence, which I'm
going to think of in a picture.
I'm going to draw
it as an array.
But it's stored
however it's stored.
We don't know.
This is an interface,
not an implementation.
So we have x 0, x 1, x 2, x 3.
And let's say I
insert at position 2.
Position 2 is here.
So I come in with
my new x, and I
would like x to be the
new x 2, but I don't
want to lose any information.
If I did set_at 2, then I
would erase this and replace it
with x.
But I want to do insert_at,
which means all of these guys,
conceptually, are
going to shift over
by 1 in terms of their indices.
Then, I would get this
picture that's one bigger.
And now I've got the new x.
I've got what was the
old x 2, which I don't--
I hesitate to call x 2 because
that's its old name, not
its new name.
I'm going to draw arrows to
say, these guys get copied over.
These ones are
definitely unchanged.
Our new x 2, which
prime is x This
is x3 prime, 4 prime, and so on.
I want to be careful here--
and of course, the new n prime
is n plus 1.
I want to be careful about the
labeling, because the key--
what makes insert_at interesting
is that, later, when I call
get_at, it's with
the new indexing.
So previously, if I did get_at
at 2, I would get this value.
And afterwards, if
I did get_at at 2,
I would get the new value.
If I did get_at
at 3 down here, I
would get the value
that used to be X 2.
That's maybe hard to track.
But this is a conceptually
very useful thing
to do, especially when
you're inserting or deleting
at the ends.
So we're going to define, in
particular, insert and delete
first and last.
These are sometimes given--
if you have an insert,
it has an x.
If you do a delete,
it has no argument.
This means insert_at the
beginning of the array, which
would be like adding it here.
And insert_last means
adding it on here.
insert_last doesn't
change the indices
of any of the old items.
That's a nice feature
of insert_last.
Insert-first
changes all of them.
They all get incremented by 1.
And we're also interested
in the similar things here.
We could do get-first or
-last or set-first or -last,
which are the obvious special
cases of get_at and set_at.
Now, these special
cases are particularly
interesting in an
algorithms context.
If you were a mathematician,
you would say, well,
why do I even bother?
This is just shorthand for a
particular call to get or set.
But what makes it interesting
from a data structures
perspective is that we care
about algorithms for supporting
these operations.
And maybe, the
algorithm for supporting
get-first or set-first, or in
particular, insert-first or
insert_last, might
be more efficient.
Maybe we can solve
this problem better
than we can solve insert_at.
So while, ideally,
we could solve
the entire dynamic sequence
interface constant time
preparation, that's
not actually possible.
You can prove that.
But special cases of
it-- where we're just
inserting and leading from
the end, say-- we can do that.
That's why it's interesting to
introduce special cases that we
care about.
Cool.
That's the definition of the
dynamic sequence interface.
Now, we're going to
actually solve it.
Our first data structure for
this is called linked lists.
You've taken, probably-- you've
probably seen linked lists
before at some point.
But the main new
part here is, we're
going to actually analyze them
and see how efficiently they
implement all of these
operations we might care about.
First, review.
What is a linked list?
We store our items
in a bunch of nodes.
Each node has an item
in it and a next field.
So you can think of
these as class objects
with two class variables, the
item and the next pointer.
And we assemble those into
this kind of structure
where we store--
in the item fields, we're going
to store the actual values
that we want to represent
in our sequence, x 0
through x n minus 1, in order.
And then we're going to use
the next pointers to link these
all together in that order.
So the next pointers are what
actually give us the order.
And in addition, we're going
to keep track of what's
called the head of the list.
The data structure is going
to be represented by a head.
If you wanted to, you
could also store length.
This could be the
data structure itself.
And it's pointing to all of
these types of data structures.
Notice, we've just seen an
array-based data structure,
which is just a static
array, and we've
seen a pointer-based
data structure.
And we're relying on the fact
that pointers can be stored
in a single word, which means
we can de-reference them--
we can see what's on the
other side of the pointer--
in constant time in
our word RAM model.
In reality, each of these
nodes is stored somewhere
in the array of the computer.
So maybe each one
is two words long,
so maybe one node is--
the first node is here.
Maybe the second node is here.
The third node is here.
They're in some arbitrary order.
We're using this fact, that we
can allocate an array of size n
in linear time--
in this case, we're
going to have arrays of size 2.
We can just say, oh, please
give me a new array of size 2.
And that will make us
one of these nodes.
And then we're storing pointers.
Pointers are just indices
into the giant memory array.
They're just, what is the
address of this little array?
If you've ever wondered how
pointers are implemented,
they're just numbers that
say where, in memory, is
this thing over here?
And in memory, they're
in arbitrary order.
This is really nice because
it's easy to manipulate
the order of a linked
list without actually
physically moving nodes around,
whereas arrays are problematic.
Maybe it's worth mentioning.
Let's start analyzing things.
So we care about these
dynamic sequence operations.
And we could try to apply
it to the static array data
structure, or we could try
to implement these operations
in a static array.
It's possible, just not
going to be very good.
And we can try to implement
it with linked lists.
And it's also not
going to be that great.
Let's go over here.
Our goal is the
next data structure,
which is dynamic arrays.
But linked lists and
static arrays each
have their advantages.
Let's first analyze dynamic
sequence operations,
first on a static array
and then on a linked list.
On a static array,
I think you all see,
if I try to insert at the
beginning of the static array--
that's kind of the worst case.
If I insert first, then
everybody has to shift over.
If I'm going to
maintain this invariant,
that the ith item in
the array represents--
I guess I didn't write
it anywhere here.
Maybe here.
Static array.
We're going to maintain
this invariant that a of i
represents x i.
If I want to maintain
that at all times, when
I insert a new
thing in the front,
because the indices of all
the previous items change,
I have to spend time
to copy those over.
You can do it in linear
time, but no better.
Static array.
Insert and delete anywhere
costs theta n time--
actually, for two reasons.
Reason number one is that,
if we're near the front,
then we have to do shifting.
What about insert or delete
the last element of an array?
Is that any easier?
Because then, if I insert
the very last element,
none of the indices change.
I'm just adding a new element.
So I don't have to do shifting.
So can I do insert and
delete last in constant time
in a static array?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: No, because
the size is constant.
ERIK DEMAINE: No, because
So our model is that
remember allocation model is
that we can allocate a
static array of size em
but it's just a size
n I can't just say
please make it bigger
by 1 I need I need space
to store this extra element.
And if you think about where
things are in memory, when
you call to this
memory allocator, which
is part of your
operating system,
you say, please give
me a chunk of memory.
It's going to place them in
various places in memory,
and some of them might
be next to each other.
So if I try to grow
this array by 1,
there might already
be something there.
And that's not possible
without first shifting.
So even though, in
the array, I don't
have to do any
shifting, in memory,
I might have to do shifting.
And that's outside the model.
So we're going to stick
to this model of just--
you can allocate memory.
You can also de-allocate memory,
just to keep space usage small.
But the only way
to get more space
is to ask for a new array.
And that new array won't be
contiguous to your old one.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: What
is the dynamic array
will be the next topic, so
maybe we'll come back to that.
Yeah?
In a static array, you're just
not allowed to make it bigger.
And so you have to
allocate a new array, which
we say takes linear time.
Even if allocating the new
array didn't take linear time,
you have to copy all
the elements over
from the old array
to the new one.
Then you can throw
away the old one.
Just the copying
from an array of size
n to an array of size n plus
1, that will take linear time.
So static arrays are really
bad for dynamic operations--
no surprise.
But you could do them.
That's static array.
Now, linked lists are going
to be almost the opposite--
well, almost.
If we store the length, OK,
we can compute the length
of the array very quickly.
We can insert and delete at
the front really efficiently.
If I want to add a new item as
a new first item, then what do?
I do I allocate a new
node, which I'll call x.
This is insert-first of x.
I'll allocate a new
array of size 2.
I'm going to change--
let me do it in red.
I'm going to change
this head pointer.
Maybe I should do that later.
I'm going to set the next
pointer here to this one,
and then I'm going
to change this head
pointer to point to here.
And, boom, now I've
got a linked list.
Again, we don't know anything
about the order and memory
of these lists.
We just care about
the order that's
represented implicitly
by following
the next pointers repeatedly.
Now, I've got a new list that
has x in front, and then x 0,
and then x 1, and so on.
So insert- and delete_first,
at least are really efficient.
We won't get much
more than that,
but the linked list, insert- and
delete_first are constant time.
So that's cool.
However, everything else
is going to be slow.
If I want to get the 10th
item in a linked list,
I have to follow these
pointers 10 times.
I go 0, 1, 2, 3, and so on.
Follow 10 next pointers
and I'll get the 10th item.
Accessing the ith item is
going to take order i time.
Get- and set_at need i time,
which, in the worst case,
is theta n.
We have sort of complementary
data structures here.
On the one hand, a static
array can do constant time
get_at/set_at.
So it's very fast at
the random access aspect
because it's an array.
Linked lists are very
bad at random access,
but they're better
at being dynamic.
We can insert and delete--
at the beginning, at least--
in constant time.
Now, if we want to
actually insert and delete
at a particular position,
that's still hard,
because we have to
walk to that position.
Even inserting and leading
at the end of the list
is hard, although
that's fixable.
And maybe I'll leave that for
problem session or problem set.
But an easy-- here's
a small puzzle.
Suppose you wanted
to solve get-last
efficiently in a linked list.
How would you solve
that in constant time?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Doubly linked list.
ERIK DEMAINE:
Doubly linked list.
It's a good idea, but
actually not the right answer.
That's an answer to the
next question I might ask.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: [INAUDIBLE]
pointer to the last element.
That's all we need here.
And often, a doubly
linked list has this.
They usually call this
the tail-- head and tail.
And if we always just store
a pointer to the last list--
this is what we call data
structure augmentation,
where we add some extra
information to the data
structure and--
we have to keep it up
to date all the time.
So if we do an
insert_last or something,
insert_last also becomes
easy because I can just
add a new node here and
update the pointer here.
delete_last is trickier.
That's where you get
a doubly linked list.
But whenever I add something
to the end of this list,
I have to update the
tail pointer also.
As long as I maintain this,
now, suddenly get-last
is fast in constant time.
So linked lists are great if
you're working on the ends,
even dynamically.
Arrays are great if you're
doing random access and nothing
dynamic--
nothing adding or deleting
at the ends or in the middle.
Our final goal for
today is to get
sort of the best of both
worlds with dynamic arrays.
We're going to try to get
all of the good running times
of linked lists and all
of the good running times
of static arrays.
We won't get quite all of
them, but most of them.
And in some sense,
another way to describe
what these introductory
lectures are about
is telling you about how
Python is implemented.
What we're going to talk
about next, dynamic arrays,
I've alluded to many times.
But these are what
Python calls lists.
You don't have to implement
a dynamic array by hand
because it's already built
into many fancy new languages
for free, because
they're so darn useful.
This lecture is about how
these are actually implemented
and why they're efficient.
And in recitation
nodes, you'll see
how to actually
implement them if all you
had were static arrays.
But luckily, we
have dynamic arrays,
so we don't have to
actually implement them.
But inside the
Python interpreter,
this is exactly
what's happening.
The idea is to relax
the constraint--
or the invariant, whatever--
that the size of
the array we use
equals n, which is the number
of items in the sequence.
Remember, in the
sequence problem,
we're supposed to
represent n items.
With a static array, we
allocated an array of size
exactly n.
So let's relax that.
Let's not make it exactly n.
Let's make it roughly n.
How roughly, you can
think about for a while.
But from an algorithms
perspective,
usually, when we say
roughly, we mean throw away
constant factors.
And that turns out to be
the right answer here.
It's not always
the right answer.
But we're going to enforce
that the size of the array
is theta n--
probably also greater
than or equal to n.
0.5 n would not be very helpful.
So it's going to be
at least n, and it's
going to be at most
some constant times n.
2n, 10n, 1.1 times n.
Any of these
constants will work.
I'm going to use 2n here, but
there are lots of options.
And now, things
almost work for free.
There's going to be
one subtlety here.
And I'm going to focus on--
we're still going to maintain
that the ith item of the array
represents x i.
This data structure--
let me draw a picture.
We've got an array of some size.
The first few items are
used to store the sequence.
But then, there's going to be
some blank ones at the end.
Maybe we'll keep track of this--
so the data structure itself is
going to have an array and it's
going to have a length.
Something like this.
We're also going to keep
track of the length.
So we know that the
first length items
are where the data is, and
the remainder are meaningless.
So now, if I want to go and do
an insert_last, what do I do?
I just go to a of
length and set it to x.
And then I increment length.
Boom.
Easy.
Constant time.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: How do
you have enough room.
Indeed, I don't.
This was an incorrect algorithm.
But it's usually correct.
As long as I have
extra space, this
is all I need to
do for insert_last.
But I am also going to
store the size of the array.
This is the actual--
this whole thing is size,
and this part is length.
Length is always going to be
less than or equal to size.
And so there's a problem.
If length equals size, then
I don't have any space.
Just add to end
unless n equals size.
I'm using n length
for the same thing.
So length here is the same as n.
That's our actual
number of things
we're trying to represent.
And size-- this is great.
This is the interface size.
This is what we're
trying to represent.
And this is the
representation size.
This is the size of my array.
These are the
number of items I'm
trying to store in that array.
This is the interface
versus data structure.
Here's the interface.
Here's the data structure.
OK, cool.
What do I do in the
case when n equals size?
I'm going to have to
make my array bigger.
This should sound just
like static arrays.
For static arrays, we made
our array bigger every time
we inserted.
And that was this linear
cost of allocation.
We're going to do
that sometimes.
With static arrays, we had
to do it every single time,
because size equaled n.
Now, we have some flexibility.
We're only going
to do it sometimes.
It's like, cookies are a
sometimes food, apparently,
according to modern
Cookie Monster.
I don't understand.
But if n equals
size, we're going
to allocate a new
array of size--
any suggestions?
AUDIENCE: Bigger.
ERIK DEMAINE: Bigger.
I like it.
Greater than size.
How much bigger?
AUDIENCE: Twice.
ERIK DEMAINE: Twice.
JASON KU: Five things.
ERIK DEMAINE: Five things.
Size plus 5?
Come on, Jason.
Trolling me.
All right.
There are a couple of
natural choices here.
One is a constant factor larger.
You could use 1.1, or
1.01, or two, or 5, or 10.
They will all work.
Or you could use Jason's
trolling answer of size
plus a constant, like 5.
Why is this bad?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: You'll
have to do it again.
You'll have to
resize frequently.
When?
Five steps later.
In the original
static array, we were
reallocating every single time.
That's like n plus 1.
If we do n plus 5, that
really doesn't change things
if we ignore constant factors.
Now, we'll have to spend linear
time every five steps instead
of linear time every one step.
That's still linear time
per operation, just,
we're changing the
constant factor.
Whereas 2 times
size, well, now we
have to think a
little bit harder.
Let's just think
about the case where
we're inserting at
the end of an array.
Let's say we do n insert_lasts
from an empty array.
When do we resize?
Well, at the beginning--
I guess I didn't say what
we do for an empty array.
Let's say size equals 1.
We can insert one item for free.
As soon as we insert the second
item, then we have to resize.
That seems bad.
Immediately, we have to resize.
Then we insert the third item.
OK, now let's draw a picture.
So we start with one item.
We fill it up.
Then, we grow to size 2,
because that's twice 1.
Then we fill it up.
Immediately, we have
to resize again.
But now we start to
get some benefit.
Now, we have size 4, and
so we can insert two items
before we have to resize.
And now, we're
size 8, and we get
to insert four items
before we refill.
This is going to resize--
and again, resizes
are expensive both
because we have to pay to
allocate the new array--
I drew it as just extending
it, but in fact, we're
creating a whole
new array, and then
we have to copy all
of the items over.
So there's the allocation cost
and then the copying costs.
It's linear either way.
But we're going to resize
at n equals 1, 2, 4, 8,
16-- you know this sequence.
All the powers of 2,
because we're doubling.
That is exactly powers of 2.
So we pay a linear cost.
This resize cost, the
allocation and the copying,
is going to be-- it's
linear each time.
So it's 1 plus 2 plus
4 plus 8 plus 16.
Really, I should write
this as sum from i
equals 1 to roughly log n.
Log base 2 of n is
lG of 2 to the i.
If you want a terminus
here, it's roughly n.
It's actually the next--
the previous power of
2 of n, or something.
But that won't matter.
That will just affect
things by a constant factor.
What is the sum of 2 to the i?
This is a geometric series.
Anyone know the answer?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: 2 to the
top limit plus 1 minus 1.
Yeah.
So this is the identity.
Sum of 2 to the i from i equals
1 to k is 2 to the k plus 1,
plus 1 minus 1.
So the plus 1 is upstairs.
The minus one is downstairs.
An easy way to remember this
is if you think in binary--
as we all should.
We're computer scientists.
2 to the i means you
set the ith bit to 1.
Here's a bit string.
This is the ith bit.
This is 2 to the i.
0 is down here.
If I sum them all up, what that
means is, I'm putting 1s here.
And if you think about what this
means, this is up to k from 0--
sorry, I should
do 0 to be proper.
If I write-- that's
the left-hand side.
The right-hand side is 2 to the
k plus 1, which is a 1 here,
and the rest 0s.
So if you know your
binary arithmetic,
you subtract-- if you add
1 to this, you get this.
Or if you subtract 1
from this, you get this.
This is why this identity holds.
Or the higher-level
thing is to say, oh,
this is a geometric series.
So I know-- you
should know this.
I'm telling you now.
Geometric series are dominated
by the last term-- the biggest
term.
If you have any series you can
identify as geometric, which
means it's growing at
least exponentially,
then in terms of
theta notation, you
can just look at the last term
and put a theta around it,
and you're done.
So this is theta
of the last term,
like 2 to the log
n, which is theta n.
Cool.
Linear time.
Linear time for all
of my operations.
I'm doing n operations here,
and I spent linear total time
to do all of the resizing.
That's good.
That's like constant
each, kind of.
The "kind of" is
an important notion
which we call amortization.
I want to say an
operation takes t of n
amortized time if, let's say,
any k of those operations
take, at most, k
times t of n time.
This is a little bit
sloppy, but be good enough.
The idea is here, if
this works for n or k,
to do n operations from
an empty array here
takes linear time,
which means I would
call this constant amortized.
Amortized means a particular
kind of averaging--
averaging over the
sequence of operations.
So while individual
operations will be expensive,
one near the end, when I
have to resize the array,
is going to take linear time
just for that one operation.
But most of the
operations are cheap.
Most of them are constant.
So I can think of
charging that high cost
to all of the other operations
that made it happen.
This is averaging over
the operation sequence.
Every insert_last over there
only takes constant time,
on average, over the sequence
of operations that we do.
And so it's almost constant.
It's not quite as good
as constant, worst case,
but it's almost as good.
And it's as good
as you could hope
to do in this dynamic
array allocation model.
Let me put this into a table.
And you'll find these in
the lecture notes, also.
We have, on the top,
the main operations
of sequence interface, which we
will revisit in lecture seven.
We'll see some other
data structures for this.
Get_at and set_at
in the first column.
Insert_ and delete_first,
insert_ and delete_last,
insert_ and delete_at
an arbitrary position.
We've seen three
data structures now.
Arrays were really
good at get_at/set_at.
They took constant time.
That's the blue one.
We're omitting the thetas here.
All of the other operations
took linear time,
no matter where they were.
Linked lists were really good
at insert- and delete_first.
They took constant time,
but everything else
took linear time,
in the worst case.
These new dynamic arrays
achieve get_at and set_at
in constant time because they
maintain this invariant here
that a of i equals x i.
So we can still do get-
and set_at quickly.
And we also just
showed that insert_last
is constant amortized.
delete_last, you don't
have to resize the array.
You could just decrease
length and, boom,
you've deleted the last item.
It's not so satisfying,
because if you insert n items
and then delete n
items, you'll still
have an array of size theta n,
even though your current value
of n is 0.
You can get around that
with a little bit more
trickery, which are described
in the lecture notes.
But it's beyond the-- we're
only going to do very simple
amortized analysis
in this class--
to prove that that
algorithm is also constant
amortized, which it is.
You'll see in 046, or you
can find it in the CLRS book.
That's it for today.